here to break this all down for us and
other breaking news Saul weisenberg
former deputy independent counsel Fox
News contributor as well as David Schoen
former Trump impeachment lawyer Saul
explained to us what is going on here I
think this came as a surprise to some
people today that indeed the walls may
be closing in and not on Trump this time
but on Hunter
well Laura it's not a it shouldn't have
been a surprise because he's under you
know there's a criminal information
filed against Hunter on the gun charge
and so Speedy Trial Act comes into play
and after a certain amount of days the
government has to has to indict him and
so that's what the judge pointed out on
August 31st she said to the parties hey
what what what's going on and today the
government said we're going to indict
him by September 29th because we have to
under the Speedy Trial Act and David for
Hunter's Council to be saying no no no
no no no we're abiding by this other
agreement that the judge was seemed
blindsided by uh when it was first
presented to the court
um how does that hold up well you know
Abby Lowell is one of the most
experienced criminal defense lawyers in
the country and you can be sure that he
recognized what you call the sweetheart
deal for exactly what it was and he'll
fight tooth and nail to try to enforce
it there's the United States Supreme
Court case from 1971 Santa Bella versus
New York work that allows a lawyer a
defendant to move for specific
performance make the plea deal happen
based on representations made by the
prosecution but it's going to be a tough
way to go in this case I think because
remember it fell apart because there
clearly was not a meeting of the minds
between the defense team and the
government in that case that required
one of his lawyers Mr Clark to withdraw
because he's going to be a witness but
they're going to certainly have a battle
over whether to enforce that plea
agreement or not and I think Abby Lowe
is right to try to force that but
remember also the judge never had to
accept it the judge could have rejected
that plea as she didn't wanted to do
additional uh consideration of it so I
think that's going to be a tough battle
I I'm skeptical of the whole process I'm
skeptical of anything that happens with
Mr Weiss now I think that was a sham
appointing him as special counsel I
think Abby Lowell if push comes to shove
is going to challenge that appointment
it violates 600.3 the special counsel
regulations because Mr Weiss is a part
of the justice department I think you'll
see all kinds of battles if they don't
allow him to enforce the agreement well
Saul what's your take on that because I
mean my gut is that it's so ridiculous
that even in this court it wouldn't be
accepted and they wouldn't be able to go
with it am I seeing this incorrectly
well first of all I think David meant to
say he referred to the plea agreement I
think he meant the diversion agreement
because both sides agree the plea
agreement is off uh I think
um I think there might be I might be a
little in a different position than
David on this I I think they've got a
real shot at enforcing the diversion
agreement Abby lowland the hunter Biden
defense team and if they do that's
that's the end of the story for the gun
charges but not only that if that broad
immunity provision in the diversion
agreement is valid they're not going to
be able to prosecute Hunter for any tax
crimes because it clearly covers other
tax offenses well David think about that
we have this Trail albeit it's kind of
difficult sometimes to follow but
through all these you know you know
shell corporations and all these
accounts that ultimately end up getting
funneled back to the Biden family now
was all that income declared we had a
lot of you know fake email addresses
used and this time period as well was
the income declared I don't think we
know the answer to that do we we do not
we I don't even think we've scratched
the surface on all that was going on in
the machinations with the Biden family I
don't know that we ever will
um the other reason I think by the way
this gun judges the Sham they well know
about the rahimi decision in the fifth
circuit that's a decision that you know
throughout a bar to gun possession based
on the domestic violence problem so here
uh it's not a big reach in fact one
might say it's less onerous to say that
we're not going to be able to uphold a
conviction for saying no to being a drug
user an unlawful drug user on this
application that the right to carry a
firearm or possess a firearm trumps that
under Bruin and so on so I think the
whole thing is for show personally now
even CNN and though so hold on one
second it's finally it seems to be
catching on maybe and admitting Hunter's
legal woes may go a little deeper watch
there's the question about whether this
investigation would broaden further or
whether there are other potential crimes
that are now back on the table you know
they brought up the potential you know
foreign agent dealing so look Hunter
Biden now has a host of problems that he
didn't have or didn't think he had a
couple of weeks ago
so they want this to go away I mean they
they don't want this flying around next
year during the election because it
taints Biden I don't care what anyone
says the Biden family got rich during
this time period he's in public service
for 50 plus years yet uh obviously if
the Sun is doing well he's very happy
and looks like influence pedaling to
most people have any common sense
here's another reason they don't want it
to happen Laura let's say that the
courts hold that the diversion agreement
is off and The Government Can prosecute
wise can prosecute Hunter for either
being on drugs when he purchased the gun
or lying about it because under the
diversion agreement they didn't charge
him with lying and buying but they could
still charge him with that if they do it
by October 12th so let's say they do
that what's Hunter going to do he's
going to go into court and he's going to
say under the Bruin decision of the
Supreme Court this is unconstitutional
you can't charge me but Laura that's the
same decision that President Biden said
was an affront to Common Sense and
confront to the Constitution his own son
his own son is going to be arguing in
different positions so it isn't going to
be pretty yeah so David they rely on
precedent that Biden previously slammed
I mean that's just kind of par for the
course here on both sides do that but in
the end I think this does it past the
straight face test the smell test for
most Americans watching this I mean you
guys are you know incredibly experienced
White Collar litigators you understand
how this process works for most
Americans watching this it can be
confusing they kind of get what's going
on will this be something that
ultimately is a political matter
regardless of what happens on the legal
side as a political matter does damage
Joe Biden I think there's that very real
possibility it depends on how long it
drags on also I think the American
people have seen enough of this if it's
going to tarnish it that it already has
I think you know Hunter is a pitiful
case unfortunately I mean I don't know
that anybody has any interest in seeing
this prosecution the question is how
much of the underlying facts is going to
be investigated and exposed I don't
think again that we've even scratched
the surface and that's the real
political risk I think now I think the
left has just decided it's perfectly
fine for the bidens to become
multi-millionaires while he's in office
I mean they they just have no problem
with that meanwhile Saul something you
and I have talked about before but it's
gaining traction as you and I predicted
it would this group called citizens for
responsibility and ethics in Washington
I love it called crew filed this lawsuit
to borrow former president Trump from
the primary ballot in Colorado arguing
that he's ineligible to run for the
White House citing the 14th Amendment
Saul um this is going to be replicated
elsewhere the Attorney General in uh
Colorado has said she's waiting for
further clarification this is ultimately
going to go to the Supreme Court what of
this now
well I think the these uh private groups
and private citizens might have a
standing problem but I think one of
these state attorney generals uh or even
under their Theory a county official is
going to make the decision to leave
Trump off the ballot it's going to go to
the courts I think it's going to go to
the Supreme Court fairly rapidly and I
think they are going to rule that you
cannot take former president Trump off
the ballot without some kind of
enabling statute and a Judicial finding
as I pointed out before there is a
statute on the books a criminal statute
prohibiting Insurrection or rebellion
and saying that if you're guilty you
can't run you can no longer hold Office
to me that's the application of that
14th Amendment provision Section 3
Congress passed that almost a century
ago maybe more than a century ago and I
think that's the way the court is going
to come down you can't just have an
official deciding Trump should be off
the ballot and according to deciding
that without any kind of factual basis
yeah that's just a that's the great
Defenders of democracy David quickly
right frankly Justice Chase said that in
Griffin's case in 1869 he said there has
to be Congress has to act it's not
self-executing these two law professors
wrote the article on the University of
Pennsylvania Law review have said
otherwise but they recognize Griffin's
case is a problem for them they just say
it was wrongly decided they've concluded
there are many many reasons why I don't
think this applies yeah it's all David
thank you so much hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else